good morning it's tuesday as you can
possibly tell just from looking at the
camera lens it is a very humid day in
indianapolis but unfortunately
the beans must be harvested the first
thing you need to do is move these
bricks you've set up to foil your
nemesis the groundhog there she is in
all her beauty your number one stop for
beans beans and more beans you've been
feeling a little exhausted lately so the
garden is overgrown and wild but you
mustn't let that discourage you too much
you are after all
just a creature trying to live with a
very strange chronic condition called
consciousness today you're harvesting
cranberry beans so called not because
they taste like cranberries but because
they look like them and the pods make it
easy for you by turning a rich
variegated red and white when they're
ready to harvest this is straightforward
work despite the heat but you can't help
but think about the absurd inefficiency
of it a can of beans costs 79 cents at
the grocery store and your beans cost
triple that even before accounting for
your labor but maybe your whole life
shouldn't worship at the altar of
efficiency anyway
there's a paradox of work like this
which is that it takes energy and time
when you feel like you don't have a
surplus of either and yet doing it
leaves you feeling less tired and less
overwhelmed
although also quite sweaty once you've
picked the beans you'll want to shell
them with someone you love and while
doing so talk about your recent travels
and travails you've felt lately like
there's a distance between your mind and
your body like they are two old friends
who've drifted apart but are still
required by circumstance to spend all
their time together but idly chatting
while shelling beans makes you feel like
your mind is back inside of your body at
least for a little while and plus the
beans are pretty sometimes cranberry
beans are mostly red other times they're
speckled opening each pod is a bit like
an extremely low steak slot machine or
something and you're surprised by how
beautiful you find the beans so much so
that after you finish shelling you may
want to take up close video of them all
right time for that mizon plos if this
was your first bean harvest you'd make
some warm bean salad or something that
really celebrates the bean-ness of the
beans but no you're just gonna make some
chili you start by chopping up two
onions how will you prevent people on
the internet from making fun of your
knife skills via jump cut while in the
garden you also picked a bunch of
peppers and so you cut those up as well
along with four cloves of garlic all of
which goes into the big pot now over in
the little pot you'll want to boil some
water and toss the beans in there making
sure your video shot is out of focus you
boil those beans for 30 minutes or until
they taste good while in the big pot
once your onions are suitably
translucent you'll add two pounds of
plant-based fake hamburger you've got a
little time now so while you watch the
beans boil think about how really you're
just sort of a fleshy worm with limbs
how there's a tube that goes through the
middle of you just like there is for
many other animals perhaps you should be
a bit more forgiving of yourself you
know given that you're literally a
mammal like of course you get scared and
don't know which way to turn in your
life you're basically an advanced
squirrel anyway then you add three cans
of diced tomatoes a tablespoon of
vinegar two heaping tablespoons of chili
powder some oregano and two beers if you
ruminated long enough about being an
organism
and you did the beans will be cooked now
so you can put them in the chili as well
you let it simmer for an hour or two
hours season to taste and then serve you
eat the chili with your family including
some cousins in from out of town and it
tastes good the beans really are better
than the ones from the store or at least
you're able to tell yourself as much and
as you eat it it occurs to you that
maybe this is the point like yeah you're
just a fleshy worm with consciousness
which can feel like a lot sometimes but
that's also what allows you to share
food you worked hard on with people you
love
and who love you
hank i'll see you on friday